alors agité le chanteur de carte de
séjour
mais est-ce que tu là ta carte de séjour
laroche a privilégié car il n'y a pas de
problème je suis à dire parce qu'il ya
les bons et les mauvais destin moi je
fais partie des bons mais n'a prévu
d'après
d'après la société tmg ou une erreur et
a vécu et où j'ai vécu dans les rouges à
l'époque sur le nom six piscines vides
mais pas le moins c'est parce qu'il la
connaissait bien la balle je connais
très bien mais je ne sais pas peut-être
comprendre le même bus pour aller à vue
policière ouais parce que donc on avait
un lycée à 5 km il y avait le bus et
mais les abords des routes après quant à
elle devenue star et où tu l'a pas
retenu en tout genre à l'autre les
débuts samedi déjà un peu ce serait plus
marqué à la tête a fait son service
militaire
ah bon j'étais sûr que ces prénoms
je suis
informés d'un passeport français mettait
réforme est donc je n'aime pas trop
frontalement alpages et l'espace aérien
constamment jacques était venu ici à
calais puisque habitons et la bombe en
attend parce que j'avais mougeotte des
paperasses et de toute façon il est trop
sec d'après tout ce qu'on entend et que
donc il ya des patrons qui n'y a pas
d'argent qu'on se connaît pas et à qui
mais quand on dit beurre ça t'emmerde
number beaucoup d'immeubles beurre ça me
convient pas mais s'était rappelée vécu
je me souviens en lisez d'or il est
toujours refusée peur qu'elle touche a
entretenu ouais parce que là haut qui
disons-le et des beurs qu'elle était
sans doute jamais faire de nos libéraux
carte de séjour c'est une espèce de tout
le monde faisait référence à
l'immigration et à la préfecture et nous
c'était plutôt référence au roi de
france une carte de séjour ce que la
particule ou à oui c'est le deux séjours
c'est comme isaac de bankolé qu'à
rajouter 1 2 comme avant d'en coller
pour faire un don
c'est un gars de séjour référence à la
nouvelle aristocratie on n'allait pas
rond et qu'un jour ou l'autre mort à mon
château vi
enfant il m'arrive c'est là c'est la
troisième génération à vivre je suis
même pas si c'est la troisième fois il
est là quand le pen c'est 14% soit avec
toi comment ça ne sais pas qu'est ce que
ça vous que c'est fait je le sais que
longtemps que le fait qu'ils existent
ouais mais 14% c'est beaucoup en toi
mais j'ai pas eu besoin de chiffres pour
se tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
l'autocollant tarder dès la première
chanson on a parlé parce que bon on a
toujours parlé pas parce que de le
peindre côté contenu on parle des gens
qui ont un état d'esprit donc lé sarabia
des qui a d'été des noirs etc et des
bourses si je les avais complètement on
le dit et quand on a fait du str ans
c'était un peu ça c'était pour pour
créer une espèce de d'un côté comme de
l'autre nous dit on ne te dis que j'ai
été provoqué c'est exactement ça qu'on a
fait parce qu'il réserve qui aurait agi
d'une façon
très très mal on disait en trahisons et
des autres français qui ont dit oui la
saga jouent ils saccagent principales
chansons voilà donc ces petits signes
nous c'est ça c'est pour ça qu'on arrive
pas très bien nous tuer parce que bon
c'est un marathon des bons petits beurre
quand abonnés le dos en disant oui on
est gentil et puis c'est pas tout à fait
celle du groupe carte de séjour victime
d'une censure la télé est ce que c'est
en dehors de vos qualités musicales on
en parlait tout à l'heure mais je veux
dire est ce que qu'est ce que tu penses
qu'il censure dans certaines émissions
ou tout à fait ça fait dix inscrits en
contre ça qu'on avait dix demandes
écueil à la rame ne pas ne pas s'y passe
très mal chez certains aux oreilles de
certains
programmateurs ou est ce que c'est
et
c'est john woo ces chocs et puis et puis
encore une espèce de les habituer
surtout des intérieurs alors que nous l
algérie ce qui reste c'est des gens
aujourd'hui le cinéma américain par
exemple c'est d'exorciser ses problèmes
par rapport à la gamme dès demain en
faisant défiler si on n'a pas fait
beaucoup par exemple et j'ai des fois
nous avaient dépassées on voit des gens
qui ont vécu cette vente à jean que
c'est encore en train de parler des
saints moi je comprends pas donc ça ne
sert pas d'être d'être algérien
finalement non c'est bon parce que tu
disais que quand ils vendaient des
encyclopédies quand lé 19 ans tu te sers
vais quand même du mal à regarder
maintenant j'aurais eu des copains jude
qui se voilent côté j'avais un peu de
vie
c'est bien alors lui s'habillait
costumes quartier témoin de quartier a
raconté qu'il a perdu ses parents dans
la guerre de kippour
alors que son père a été ils étaient ils
travaillent dans les âmes
bon il sait que je conduis moi la
dernière question si demain hypothèse on
sait pas pourquoi il ya la guerre entre
la france et l'algérie
tu vas être de quel côté
[Musique]
merguez univers entre la france et la
loi pour la guerre je suis content du
côté sud la guerre entre l'angleterre et
l'argentine imagine qu'il a guère
ensuite sauté moi je suis du côté de la
paix bon je déserte
ouais je dise à plus en plus su réformer
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux